Elsa's powers were too much for this
world now we must pray they are enough
[Music]
alsa you've gone on such a journey back
in the days of the first frozen film you
were scared of your powers you wanted to
hide yourself away but by the end of
frozen - you totally own your magic gift
and now you know who you really are with
all of this newfound self-confidence
you're more powerful than ever you've
even met up with four other awesome
spirit powers and found your place in
the world we couldn't be happier for you
Alice has been searching for the truth
about her ice powers all her life and
she finally gets the answers in frozen -
which makes her extra powerful keep
watching to the end to discover what new
alliances will increase Elsa's power
even more Anna no I have my powers to
protect me Elsa's power is finally
explained first things first we can all
agree that knowledge is power and in
frozen - Elsa finally gets the answers
to all her questions about her ice
powers she spends nearly the entire
movie and the first film trying to
figure out where her magic comes from we
learned that even her parents weren't
sure about the origins of their
daughter's abilities their ship got
wrecked on their journey to Otto Holland
in their search for the truth and the
answer that Elsa eventually discovered
was that her powers were a gift not a
curse the nature spirits rewarded I
dunno for her selfless act of saving AG
narf by giving her a magical daughter
simply by knowing the reason for her
power Elsa's power is increased Elsa
finds a community in the original frozen
film Elsa is an outcast she banishes
herself from her kingdom and chooses to
live in isolation on the North Mountain
we get the perfect insight into her
frame of mind when she sings let it go
they say that no person is an island and
you really can't get through life
entirely on your own so Elsa needs to
find a community that she can thrive in
and express her powers to their fullest
even though Elsa reunites with Anna at
the end of the first movie we see that
she's still not settled at the beginning
of frozen - it's clear that Elsa isn't
totally comfortable in the family set up
and the others still don't totally
understand her when Anna asks Kristoff
as Elsa
weird to you she seems like Elsa it's
clear that Elsa isn't amongst others on
the same wavelength that's her she can't
get fully involved in Ana's game of
charades sure she's distracted by the
voice that's calling her but this kind
of endorsee constrained entertainment
just isn't her cup of tea also explains
the disconnect she's feeling when she
sings into the unknown she wonders if
the voice calling her is someone who's a
little bit like her who knows deep down
she's not where she's meant to be and
eventually she admits that she's longed
to go into the unknown
she needs to be free add amongst nature
and by the end of frozen to she's found
the perfect environment by living in the
enchanted forest amongst the other four
spirits she can finally unleash her
powers to the max Elsa connects with
Anna Elsa and Anna have always had a
tricky relationship ever since Elsa
accidentally froze her little sister's
head when they were kids they've managed
to mend their relationship at various
points along the way but Alice's still
wasn't entirely on the same page as Anna
in frozen - Elsa promises Anna we do
this together okay I promise but she
ends up betraying that promise when she
sends Anna and Olaf off in a frozen
canoe no matter how close they were
getting Elsa's still felt a disconnects
from her sister she still felt like she
couldn't fully embrace her powers and go
as far as she needed to while Anna was
around however by the end of the movie
Elsa has finally found a way to connect
with Anna without stifling her powers by
being the protector of the enchanted
forest Elsa can live in her element
while still having contact with her
sister she can connect with Anna through
letters and meetups but without having
to hold in her powers Elsa freeze
herself from imposed duty it's important
that Elsa renounces her role as queen of
arendelle this is a position that was
thrust upon her when her parents passed
away it wasn't a role that she chose for
herself by being pushed into a station
of imposed duty Elsa was limited she
couldn't use her ice powers for much
more than sparkly celebration fireworks
she couldn't unleash the full force of
her powers while she was queen of
arendelle but by passing that mantle on
to Anna who perfectly suits the role
Elsa could free herself from that
restraining responsibilities sure she
ends up in another position of power as
the protector of the Enchanted Forest
but the important difference
is that she chose that role for herself
and it's a job that lets her use her
full range of powers without restriction
Elsa knows who she is in the first
frozen movie it's clear that Elsa
suffers from self-doubt she had such a
traumatizing childhood it's no wonder
she ended up feeling like a burden she
didn't understand her true nature by
finally getting those answers in frozen
- Elsa could discover her true self she
can now embrace her powers and
everything that makes her who she is
she literally lets her hair down in
frozen - when she gets to Otto Holland
and she embraces her true self before we
reveal what new allies make Elsa even
more powerful we invite you to be the
first to watch our latest frozen videos
so if you haven't already subscribed to
the things and tap that notification
bell if you're watching on your phone go
to your YouTube settings and turn on
your notifications now back to Elsa Elsa
finds her purpose Elsa's big musical
moment on odda Holland is a major
turning point show yourself is like an
anthem of self-acceptance self
realization and self love she sings
about a friend she's always known and
how she feels like she is home
Elsa goes on to seeing about feeling so
certain that she's there for a reason
the reason she was born she's finally
finding the answer she's waited for all
her life the voice that's been calling
her is her mother who sings come my
darling homeward bound and also replies
I am found some fans have wondered
whether the voice actually belongs to
Elsa and if it is in fact Elsa herself
that has been calling out for the Ice
Queen to find her purpose
either way watching Elsa finally embrace
her true calling is such an emotional
moment else I can push herself to the
limit
not only does Elsa push herself to get
to adda Holland and discovered the truth
about the past she also goes deeper than
she's been advised to go Pappy had
warned Elsa and Anna about their journey
before they set out to the enchanted
forest Pappy told Anna magic is very
alluring without you she might lose
herself to it and going back to their
mother's lullaby about auda Holland I do
know has also warned Elsa about going
too far I do know sings about the river
dive down deep into her sound but
not too far or you'll be drowned Elsa
stands on the precipice knowing that if
she leaps down deep into the memories of
the past it will destroy her but she
does it anyway sacrificing herself to
find the truth and as she begins to
freeze she shoots out the answer to Anna
to make sure their grandfather's
betrayal is known Elsa has pushed
herself to the ultimate limit and it
takes such a huge strength to do that
with such strength comes power Elsa has
tamed her powers we're so relieved when
Elsa unfreezes and comes back bringing
back Olaf - there's some debate amongst
fan as to whether Elsa actually passes
when she freezes and comes back as a
spirit or if she simply came back to
life she certainly looks more ethereal
after her frozen moment she's paler and
more ghostly buzz like Bruni she's a
physical being capable of being hugged
by Anna so either way whether she came
back to life or is a spirit Elsa exists
in some forms and in this new form she's
totally in control of her powers she
manages to beat the water surge when the
dam comes down and reaches arendelle in
time to save the kingdom from the
massive wave her ice powers quell in the
water and all is calm and the important
point to make is that also is able to do
that because the spirits agreed she is
working together and finding harmony
with the other powers now - the fact
that she's tamed her powers stands in
stark contrast of the first movie by the
end of the original frozen film we see
that Elsa is much more in control of her
powers but she still isn't totally there
yet after all she accidentally freezes
her hands to the balcony at the
beginning of the second film but by the
end of the sequel she's owning it Elsa
can tame other powers not only does Elsa
manage to take charge of her own powers
but she also manages to control the
other spirits powers - and she does have
to use force in the end sure she
unleashes her ice powers in a battle
with the fire spirit to begin with but
then she realizes that it's actually a
cute little salamander called Bruni and
she finds that she can tame Bruni by
being kind to him and by using her own
powers to make him happy by giving him
snow piles to jump in or snowflakes to
eat she also gets playful with Gale the
wind spirit and as for NOK the water
spirit in horse form Elsa totally takes
charge
manages to rain and knock quite
literally to ride the water spirit
across the waves to odda Holland and she
finds a way to work together with a
horse and harmony this ability to not
only tame her own powers but the other
Spears powers to makes Elsa even more
powerful Elsa has four new powers to
play with as Elsa is working in harmony
with the four spirits
she now has four new powers to play with
this has practical benefits for example
Elsa is so friendly with Gale that she
can send letters to Anna thanks to the
helpful wind spirit and when earth fire
wind water and ice all connects they
make an unbeatable force else is at the
center of that power and we couldn't be
happier for her
what did you think about else's journey
in the sequel do you believe she's
happier now living in the enchanted
forest or do you wish she was still
living with Anna sound off in the
comments please give this video a big
thumbs up we'll see you next time
thanks for watching the things